what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are getting into a really
kind of picking up again with a Hal
Jordan the Green Lantern Corps it's been
a little while since we covered cover
this this part of DC rebirth but this
basically picks up with Zod's will this
is kind of like you know basically
General Zod wrecking the Green Lantern
which is actually pretty awesome but
something that I do want to talk about
here for a second is the nature of
Kryptonian powers because I've seen this
question asked before so one of the
questions that I've that I've seen it's
actually a really really good question
if Kryptonians absorbs solar radiation
shouldn't Supergirl basically be exactly
as powerful as Superman like if you took
50 Kryptonians and you set them on a
singular planet then should they all be
equally as powerful like none is more
powerful than the other and if that's
true then why is it a Supergirl is more
powerful than Superman why is General
Zod less powerful in Superman okay so
these aren't you some really really good
questions and they're they're a really
cool idea what this does is begin to
kind of answer it but the whole idea was
Supergirl to kind of address that for a
second pre-crisis which is to say up
until 1985 there was no answer to that
it was just super girls more powerful
than Superman because reasons and and
that was basically at post-crisis that
was answered by Geoff Johns I'm pretty
sure back in the mid 2000s where Kara
zor-el first showed up after the events
of crisis on Infinite Earths and the
explanation DC offered was that when she
was held in suspended animation
basically she had like solar radiation
bombarding her while she was in her
spacecraft and so she had essentially
been absorbing solar radiation for a
much longer time than Superman and
that's one of the big reasons why
there's a differentiating factor with
General Zod he was consistently shown to
have been weaker because he was
constantly catching up he had been
locked in the Phantom Zone
what will you he was supposed to be in
there for eternity but he even locked to
the Phantom Zone for a very long time
and so while Superman was absorbing
solar radiation on earth the General Zod
was just sitting in the Phantom Zone
with knows no seaming you know no way to
escape basically until he did and so
that's why General Zod has consistently
shown to be somewhere near Superman's
power or lower than Superman he's not
really shown to be real more powerful
than Superman so hopefully that kind of
cleared things up but what this does is
this basically picks up in the aftermath
of the whole battle with the controllers
now of course the controllers will
return especially with year.the the
return of the dark stars but again
because of the fact that controllers
were a group of mountains who basically
went off in and did their own thing and
became a wholly separate group from the
guardians of the universe themselves the
controllers kind of went on this
campaign to kidnap the Guardians to
convert them basically to
Tyrael eyes the more or less or kind of
SAP their energy and create more
controllers to kind of bring controllers
back what this did is it led to you know
Jon Stewart and Hal Jordan and so on and
so forth the various Green Lantern's
rescuing the guardians of the universe
and so what this means is that the
guardians are basically reforming into
their previous roles but this is a very
iffy situation and the reason for this
is because remember when it came to
everything before the new 52 basically
the old Geoff Johns run the guardians of
the universe were shown to have been a
group that was very manipulative and
housed a lot of Secrets they didn't tell
the the Green Lantern's everything they
wanted to know and when it can't when it
comes to like Jon Stewart he initially
quits and he basically decides to quit
in the face of the Reformation of the
guardians of the universe and of course
the question that kind of have is but
why though Jon Stewart basically says
the last time we had a quote-unquote you
know council of the guardians of the
universe you guys hid information you
guys ignored the warning signs of the
coming you know destruction of the of
the universe and it took you the rise of
the black Lantern's in order of you guys
to finally realize things were popping
off it was the idea that the Guardians
had become very tyrannical and so the
result is that when Jon Stewart looks at
the Reformation of the guardians of the
universe his whole idea is we're going
back to the way things used to be and I
don't want to be a part of that now
here's kind of the cool thing ganthet
and sayd our old school right they're
basically the original guardians of the
universe all the original guardians
except for those two were basically dead
it's a whole new group of guardians who
were there but this is basically a fresh
face a fresh group of people with the
exception of ganthet ganthet and sayd
but their whole response is the fact
that you realize Jon Stewart that this
is a problem is why we need you here we
don't want to become the council that
becomes despotic we want someone to be
able to keep us in check and so it's
kind of cool because it's basically
meeting halfway so of course he's
basically sent back out by the Guardians
he's told to essentially just kind of
make sure everything is in check and
then of course they tell him hey look
there's a crisis set in the sector
somewhere and you gotta send some
lanterns to check it out so of course
because this is Hal Jordan the Green
Lantern Corps Hal Jordan Karina respond
now when they get here there's basically
a race here that's kind of in the in the
Stone Age but they're essentially
building like this massive kind of
Citadel of sorts and we end up finding
out all this is being orchestrated by
General Zod now this is a very important
thing because General Zod is immediately
attacked by Hal Jordan and Kyle Rayner
and that's important because they
launched the first strike General Zod
did not do anything to provoke this
attack he was simply just there now
in reality is because General Zod
a Kryptonian bad guy he always has been
he's always done these really really
crabby terrible things but at the moment
he's not done anything wrong and so in
reality what you really have here is Hal
Jordan and company showing up on the
doorstep of General Zod whether they
knew it or not and then saying you're
coming with us
with nothing to actually charge him with
and so in response General Zod actually
breaks free of the constructs of Hal
Jordan now in truth this shouldn't
normally be allowed to happen but what
we end up finding out here is this
planet is orbiting two yellow Suns and
so what this means is that General Zod
has been absorbing twice the amount of
solar radiation that he normally has
general Zod's power level has been
jumped forward and that's why we had
this discussion at the beginning of the
video it's because we're General Zod has
been consistently catching up with
Superman in the sense that like you know
Superman gets you know he just kind of
has this level of power and and
sometimes he cuts loose sometimes he
doesn't
General Zod has always just been a
little bit weaker because he was exposed
to solar radiation later than Superman
was but being in a location where he's
absorbing twice the radiation he's
basically catching up to Superman very
very very fast and at the moment right
now he's equal to Superman in power and
so not only that and again not only do
we have General Zod here but going back
to like the action comics liner stories
of Superman liners stories
well you had like a Radek and so on and
so forth Zod still has his own little
miniature army so he's got his wife he's
got his son and he's got the Eradicator
kind of like this this old piece of
Kryptonian technology is really what he
is but this leads to a conflict between
Kyle Rayner and Hal Jordan himself now
this is very important here because what
ends up happening is you basically have
the wife of General Zod who's as
powerful as Superman General Zod himself
who's as powerful as Superman their son
who's as powerful and the Eradicator Hal
Jordan Kyle Rayner do not stand a chance
and they literally get absolutely
decimated with the greatest of ease I
mean they are laid waste to in an
instant but in the aftermath of this
ruin the mean captured of course they
basically stripped of their rings and
they're you know at least Hal Jordan is
taken before General Zod now this is
kind of the funny thing here when it
comes to Zod is a care of this one the
reasons why I always liked him so much
historically speaking when it comes to
comics you know that good you're good
guys are good guys bad guys are bad guys
what makes bad guys interesting are the
motivations behind what they do what
they do
or why they do what they do but also
like who they are and how they're
inherently written some bad guys are
just bad guys like electro is never
really an interesting villain in the
spider-man mythos until he like took
down power to the rats and freed all the
supervillains but like magneto has
always been interesting because his
character is
volved and changed so much over the
years General Zod is much the same way
when Hal Jordans brought before Zod it's
not so Zod could just start pummeling
him and saying tell me what I want to
know it's because Zod is just kind of
like let's sit down and have a
conversation let's talk now in reality
how Jordan is just kind of like I don't
want to hear you're a bad guy you got to
go that's one of the reasons why this is
interesting in the way that it's written
because you look at this and how Jordan
almost seems to be like the antagonist
here whereas you just kind of has
General Zod here on this planet now
because that is a villain you can't help
but wonder what it is that he's up to
but it is kind of intriguing now the
other half of this is that General Zod
does not know how the ring of Hal Jordan
works the ring that Hal Jordan wields
right now is not the ring that he
historically wielded Hal Jordan forged
his ring out of pure willpower it's part
and parcel to himself
basically how Jordan's ring is like his
arm or his leg or his brain or something
along those lines and so because it's
tied inherently to his willpower he's
able to literally command the ring and
have it break directly out of its cell
and return to Him and so what he is up
doing is basically flying back to Kyle
Rayner and this is when we realized that
when it comes to like this group here
this group that it's believed that that
General Zod is kind of oppressing and
forcing into slave labor it's not
actually that way instead these guys
worship General Zod now this kind of
invokes the whole idea of like the Star
Trek prime directive right I mean like
if you're in Star Trek universe the
prime directive is you cannot interact
with races that have not achieved
interstellar travel you have to allow
them to continue on their own their own
path until they eventually discover
faster than light travel and then from
there you know then you can interact
with them with this whole situation here
and it's this idea if we start messing
around with these guys if we start
causing problems then what we basically
do here is we kind of obstruct the
progression of this race but this race
looks at General Zod sees them is a guy
who can fly who's got like super speed
strength so on and so with and they see
him as a god and the result is that they
worship Him as a god and Zod has
essentially been using that to get them
to do work for him he's not been forcing
them into oppression if anything he's
kind of manipulating it but manipulating
someone is not any illegal act he hasn't
actually done anything wrong here and so
the result is that with General Zod is
kind of okay look you know we got to
take care of these two Green Lantern's
Hal Jordan essentially like binds his
ring directly to Kyle Rayner
transforming him into something akin to
like an infinite lantern basically and
then sending Kyle Rayner back to back to
OA and so it's kind of cool because Kyle
Rayner is actually bond a bond
with pure willpower now the problem with
this is that because it is such an
extreme level of power
Kyle's trying to adapt to it but this
power this this pure willpower that he's
getting it's actually like kind of
overriding his senses and what I mean by
that is that he's suffering from like a
a lacerated liver he's got broken ribs
by all standards of measurement he
should be like recovering and in surgery
right now
but this willpower he's receiving is
kind of amplifying him up to the extreme
we're just like overrides all those
sensations and so basically he feels no
pain he's just totally gassed up and
ready to go the other funny thing about
this is because because of the fact that
he's bonded with Hal Jordans willpower
he's spouting off Hal Jordan quotes he's
saying things Al Jordan would say but at
this point we kind of switch back over
to that to the guardians of the universe
themselves and again this is why the
whole situation with Jon Stewart is
somewhat tenuous because Jon Stewart is
getting what he wanted he's just
realized that it's not really what he
wanted basically what he's getting is
not what he had hoped for with the
guardians of the universe in and back in
the old days they would have just been
like Gogan Hal Jordan done and that
would have been it and they would have
said get him back by any means necessary
you know you have leave to do whatever
you have to do and they would have
fought General Zod it would have been
kind of a cool battle for a few minutes
I mean they would have won they would
have brought Hal Jordan cat meows run
Hal Jordan back with this new Guardians
a new guardian council their whole
stance is we can't be so quick to
judgment and so we basically have to
deliberate and for Jon Stewart it's so
frustrating because it's like but it's
one of our lanterns them and that's kind
of the big differentiating factor
between the guardians of the universe
and like normal people a normal human
being is basically primitive like we're
pretty basic we're pretty emotional
we're not that bright in the grand
scheme of things like people have a
tendency to let their emotions override
their common sense and so with that in
mind the guardians is kind of like okay
but like you know I realize that you
want to go get Hal Jordan but like
you're an idiot though because like
you're very emotional and you're not as
wise as we are because we've been around
for like I'm like 3 billion years or
something along those lines so like let
our 3 billion years of wisdom kind of
play out here and then when you've been
alive for three billion years and you
can kind of play that role you know
where 900 years you reach you know look
how good you know look good you will not
or whatever the hell it was you order
said to Luke Skywalker so with this
whole thing
John's kind of response is but we have
to rescue how though and this is one of
the reasons why Jon Stewart is so cool
but also one of the reasons why the the
kind of antagonistic nature of the Green
Lantern's and the the guardians of the
universe works so well because a lot of
the green that were really the
earthbound Green Lantern's for them all
I want to have their cake and eat it too
we need to be logical we need to think
things out unless it's something I
really really want then we should just
do that but like if it's not something
that what I did I really really want
well then yeah just let things play out
and we'll just kind of see what happens
I mean it's one of those things we can't
have it both ways
and so the result is that Jon Stewart
kind of takes off but he does exactly
what you would expect he'd do Guy
Gardner of course garner being Guy
Gardner basically goes in for abs you
know a kind of a core member of the
Green Lantern's it says we got to go
rescue Hal Jordan and then essentially
takes off and Jon Stewart's like I
didn't see anything as it was kind of
interesting here because what what's
happening the entire time this is going
on is Kyle weiners ring is still with
General Zod and so General Zod is
actually going through and having the
Eradicator analyzed the ring but of
course then all the Green Lantern's show
up and they basically end up facing off
against General Zod now again with Kyle
Rayner wielding essentially the the
power of two Green Lantern's it is kind
of cool here because when he shows up it
is an extreme level of willpower that he
has at his disposal and for the most
part he's able to hold his own to a
degree the problem with this is that
again you're talking about Kryptonians
that are twice as powerful as they
normally are not only that they're
actually fighting with restraints
they're just kind of like hey like hold
back a little bit and let's just kind of
see what happens unless let's just sort
of keep them at bay because what they're
doing is basically stalling that's
really all they're doing here and that's
kind of interesting because when you're
watching these Kryptonians stall against
the Green Lantern's yet still hold their
own against the Green Lantern's the
question has to become so like what
happens when they go when they go ham
like what happens when he just like
flat-out loses it and so for a minute
General Zod does that when he literally
like punches out Kyle Rayner and sends
him flying and that's why I say this is
so awesome because it kind of gives us
like this full brunt concept of like
what would happen if a full-on
Kryptonian faced off against a Green
Lantern and that Kryptonian is just like
basically Superman a level power with no
no real reason to hold back this is a
pretty cool moment here because how do
how do Orton kind of reaches out and
says look you can't keep tampering with
this power like I gave it to you so you
could get away but you have no idea what
impact this level of power is gonna have
on your body you don't know if it'll
kill you and so for a minute how Jordan
like what he actually does is he kind of
you know tries to reason with with Kyle
and then basically strips a--'s
willpower back from Carl reverting him
to his normal form kind of amplifies it
a bit and then in turn like grabs his
willpower brings it back and his ring
returns to himself and then of course
you know Hal Jordan arrives on the scene
now of course this is after
like all the Kryptonians have decimated
all the other Green Lantern's so I was
really one of these things where like
Hal Jordan is the last man standing now
again when you're talking about how
Jordan fighting here against General Zod
it's kind of a continuation of that
whole discussion that we had earlier
well of course General Zod being as
powerful as Superman he crushed Hal
Jordan before you should be able to
crush him now but it doesn't work that
way because what house one kind of says
here is look I wasn't prepared to fight
a Kryptonian who who had been exposed to
this much solar radiation I didn't
expect to see you fighting here and now
it's one of those coming book hop outs
it works but it's one of those things
that writers kind of use to sort of
adjust the story a little bit but in
turn like it's basically the willpower
of Hal Jordan facing off against the
full power of General Zod essentially
facing off against Superman here and
it's awesome because the ring allows a
person to do whatever they want to do
allows their imagination to run wild but
the ring is only as powerful as the
willpower of the person who wields it
but was cut with with Hal Jordan is a
wholly separate circumstance because the
ring is an extension of himself actually
the ring is his willpower it's not just
a thing that was given to him and so
he's basically fighting with his mind
body and soul and that's why this is so
cool is because he's able to hold his
own pretty damn well against General Zod
and actually able to like beat the crap
out of him now the other thing to
remember here is that General Zod is a
master strategist the issue with General
Zod is that by and large most of his
battles have been confined to Superman
or like Wonder Woman or something along
those lines because he's historically
been a Superman villain Superman is more
of just like hardcore punching in
different things like that and kind of
thinking about things from a different
perspective but that's always been the
nature of Zod versus Superman the
military strategist versus the guy who
just punches things and so when it comes
to this whole situation Hal Jordan his
experience when it comes to like various
forms of military combat is he is
well-versed in this not only that he
thinks about things with a little bit
more imagination and the reason why I
say this is that when he's facing off
against Zod and sending all these
different you know these have been hard
like constructs in the form of like Jets
toward him General Zod is kind of
thinking about it in a two dimensional
space there's there's front and there's
back with Hal Jordan however he just
kind of sits around and he says one of
the most important things the Air Force
taught me is that there is no real
up-and-down I mean there's up and down
and so much you have a brown in the sky
but like fights are three-dimensional
and so you have to see things around you
at all times and so that's when Zod
begins to turn around and realize that
like all these different things are
coming at him from every single
direction now it's not enough to destroy
Zod but it is enough to take him by
surprise
and that's a pretty significant feat
because when that happens it basically
allows Howard you want to take in
prisoner now
as soon as this happens the green
lanterns pop up and say you have to let
him go he hasn't actually broken any
laws here so there's nothing that we can
do because that he's essentially let go
here but it's kind of cool because
general Zod's response is we don't want
you here now this is the biggest
motivation for why General Zod is doing
all this no the whole Corps the whole
purpose of generals are the whole way he
perceives us is that Tamar Rae was the
Green Lantern of the sector the Krypton
was in when Krypton blew up and so Zod
has always held a hatred for Green
Lantern's because of the simple fact
that the Green Lantern that he perceives
that that tomar ray had failed that Omar
ray had basically screwed up in a loud
Krypton to be destroyed and so in his
mind he's like we rebuke your protection
like do whatever you want to do in this
sector but do not come here and it works
because what it means is that he would
be able to sort of function with
autonomy that nobody can really
interfere and what it is that he has
going on the other half of this is that
for Zod the reason why he was analyzing
the Ring of
Carinae which of course would return the
cow Rayner and you know they were all
kind of allowed to go free
is that what Zod wanted was the
information stored inside the ring which
no one really seemed to ask the question
of what he was doing with the ring but
what Zod was doing going through and
analyzing the ring he essentially has a
map of the universe now he has a map of
every single race in the universe every
single planet in the universe the
weapons capabilities of those races on
those planets how many Green Lantern's
are where the Green Lantern's are
stationed at all the goings-on that
exist inside the universe right now and
what it means is he has every
conceivable piece of information he
would need from a military strategic
standpoint that's a gold mine if you're
a military strategist and you can know
what the enemy's weapons are you can
know where the weapons are and you can
know how to attack those weapons without
being seen you've basically won the war
especially if they don't know that you
have that information because anything
you can implement that in any
conceivable way that you want to and so
what this does right now is it makes
General Zod quite possibly the most
dangerous being in the universe but
something else that I want you guys to
consider this is kind of a war this is
kind of an interesting scenario because
it sort of points of the idea of what
direction he'll draw might be going in
it's one panel it's not very long but
but Hal Jordan starts talking to Jon
Stewart about the idea of ending
villains permanently he's just kind of
like what do you think about the idea
that like if we got rid of villains like
if we face up against a villain and they
were gone for good would that really be
a bad thing and in reality it wouldn't a
dead man cannot be a repeat of
Hal Jordan is not really wrong here it's
not necessarily the worst idea to kill
every criminal who commits a crime the
problem with this is like evidence and
different things like that
it is kind of interesting and it kind of
points of the idea that Hal Jordan sort
of falling down this road of possibly
becoming a bad guy we don't really know
but anyway if you guys are new here two
comments explain make sure you guys have
the sub button to become part of the rob
poor if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
you
[Music]